عام مضى وقف خلاله وباؤو كورونا عائقا
امام تحقيق الاقتصاد الصيني نسب النمو
المرجوه ولا تشير التوقعات الى نمو الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي باكثر من ثلاثه في المئه
هذا العام
فمع اسوء تفشل في البلاد منذ عامين اغلق
وباء وكرونا مدينه شنغهاي عاصمه الصين
الاقتصاديه والماليه لمده شهرين
ولاحقت بها مناطق تعتبر مراكز التصنيع
الرئيسيه في الصين ما اضر مباشره بالنشاط
الصناعي وحدات قيود مكافحه انتشار الفيروس
التي فرضتها السلطات على مدار العام من
قدره المواطنين على الانفاق
ليتراجع نموه مبيعات التجزئه الى نحو
ثلاثه في المئه»
على قطاع نقل البضائع خاصه بالتالي اذا
وبات فالاسعار نتيجه نقص السلع تعرض قطاع
العقارات الصيني الذي يمثل نحو 30% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لازمه حاده خلال
العامه اصابت بعد اكبر مطورين مساكن في
البلاد ما دفع الحكومه الصينيه للاعلان عن
خطه دعم تجاوزت مليارات دولار لتعزيز
الشركات الصغيره وقطاع العقارات
المنزليه في الصين ليس مرتفعا نسبيا ولكن
الجميع متشائمون بشان افاق سوق العقارات
ومع توقعات بفرض ضريبه العقارات فانها
حافظه شراء المنازل سيكون ضعيفا للغايه
على القطاع الخاص
وبعقوبات فرضتها الولايات المتحده على
قطاع التكنولوجيا الصينيه خسرت شركات مثل
علي بابا وتنسنت ما يزيد على التريليون
دولار من قيمتها السوقيه مع ادى الى رجوع
مبيعاتها وتسريح عشرات الالاف من موظفيها
ليرتفع معدل البطاله بين الشباب الصيني
ويتجاوز خمسه في المئه يتوقع مراقبون
نمونا ناتج المحلي الاجمالي الصينيه بنحو
اربعه في المئه خلال العام القادم وسط
اعاده فتح الاقتصاد غير ان اخرين يرون ان
ذلك غير مؤكد في ظل ظروف ماليه واقتصاديه
عالميه متعثره
وتصاعدا في التوترات الجيوسياسيه
ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره بيجين